bonjour a tous invités de sao qu'a dit
ce matin lui plenel président et
fondateur du site internet mediapart en
ayant aussi vous êtes là pour ça vous
êtes le fils d'alain plenel l'ancienne
figure est viré vice-recteur de la
martinique bonjour et du pénal bonjour
votre lettre votre père à la plenel a
été donc je le disais vice-recteur de la
martinique de 1955 à 1960 je ne me
trompe
et vous allez inaugurer domaine l'école
qui portera son nom au morne-rouge le
choix de cette commune n'est pas un
auteur on est à quelques jours après les
émeutes de décembre 59 et votre père
prononce un discours oui ce geste qui
est fait pas par moi c'est par le peuple
martiniquais qui va à cette occasion
avec la municipalité du morne-rouge au
fond c'est son histoire c'est l'histoire
du peuple martiniquais de ces luttes de
ces résistances de sa fierté et mon père
fait ce qu'il a fait parce que le peuple
martiniquais l'a amené à le faire alors
qu'at-il fait c'était après les émeutes
de décembre 59 ou trois jeunes
collégiens ont été tuées assassinées il
n'avait rien fait de mal et mon père en
tant que patron de du système scolaire
il avait beaucoup beaucoup travaillé
pour l'école il avait beaucoup construit
d'école il y avait encore un peu
d'analphabétisme à la martinique à cette
époque qui la veille s'était c'était un
très bonne administrateurs et je crois
que tout le monde de l'éducation s'en
souvient et cet homme du couvent a
inauguré au morne-rouge une école est là
dans ce climat de tension on est
quelques jours après les émeutes
il y à un bateau de guerre qui arrive
dans la rade de fort de france il y a
une tension une répression et un
secrétaire général de la préfecture qui
est très répressif et qui veut
absolument faire tomber des têtes et mon
père qui est un représentant au fond de
l'ordre colonial il ya le préfet il ya
le vice-recteur rial général mais il est
normalement de ce côté là et bien cet
homme franchi cette frontière symbolique
et je crois que c'est cela qui fait
qu'il est resté très fort dans la
mémoire du peuple martiniquais
on vous reproche d'être
proche justement du peuple martiniquais
simplement on lui reproche au fond
d'être du côté de la justice ce n'est
pas être simplement proche du peuple
martiniquais c'est de dire que il ya
l'égalité des droits et qu'il dit dans
ce discours que ce qui s'est passé ces
trois jours de décembre pour lui lui
font penser à un souvenir de jeunesse à
rennes dans sa ville de jeunesse il y
avait la statue d'un polytechnicien qui
est mort lors des trois glorieuses en
1830 et il dit l'expression va faire son
chemin
c'étaient les trois glorieuses du peuple
martiniquais qui se soulevait contre
quoi contre le racisme contre la justice
pour l'égalité est d'ailleurs ces
émeutes vont provoquer des changements
au final les élus vont se mobiliser tous
les partis politiques vont faire des
déclarations communes
donc il dit moi je ne suis pas la france
qui a tué ces jeunes je suis une autre
france et c'est ça que je voulais vous
dire c'est cette idée du déplacement
on n'est pas assigné à être là où où on
est on est en apparence et je crois que
voilà c'est c'est cette idée que autour
de la révolte contre l'injustice
on peut bouger alors pour avoir prononcé
ce discours votre père est rétrogradé et
il part en exil en algérie numérique où
il va rencontrer entre autres geeks à
bord masson daniel boukman pour ne citer
que ceux là oui bien sûr cirque il va
continuer à être solidaire des luttes
à l'époque on disait pour l'autonomie
notamment le front antillo guyanais avec
edouard glissant et bien d'autres et
puis donner des interviews des
déclarations et ça ce serait
insupportable pour un fonctionnaire
d'autorité donc il va être cassée par
l'état français et là il va choisir
suivant je pourrais dire les traces de
frantz fanon l'empreinte martiniquaise
toujours qui pour lui et son coup de
coeur un profondément de toute sa vie
eh bien il va pardon aller en exil en
algérie où il va retrouver d'autres
continuaient guadeloupéens martiniquais
exilés parce qu'ils avaient été
solidaires comme frantz fanon du peuple
algérien les noms que vous avez cités
qui venaient tous à la maison c'était le
lieu c'était une sorte d'enclavé
antillaise à alger où on se retrouvait
tous et où
se souvenait du pays votre père indigné
révolté un homme très calme
un homme très tranquille pas un homme de
coller un pas un homme de parti il n'a
jamais été membre d'un parti
un homme libre simplement un homme qui a
dit non et qui a dit non sans calcul
sans réfléchir en termes de carrière en
termes davantage en termes de projets un
moment il s'est dit ce n'est pas
supportable je vais pas simplement
garder ça pour moi je dis non c'est ça
le symbole du discours du morne rouge et
vous avez prononcé ce mot indignés dans
son chemin d'ailleurs alger il croise
quelqu'un qui va combattre pour qu'il
soit réhabilité en tant qu'admin en tant
qu'administrateur sa sagesse après 80
c'est stéphane hessel l'auteur
d'indignez-vous qui disait à un moment
voilà faut dire non à l'injustice et je
remercie du fond du coeur la
municipalité de morne rouge sa mère
madame de liste ch'ti et l'ancien maire
monsieur petits qui ont qui ont fait ce
choix parce que en effet c'était là que
pouvait être cette trace de mémoire dont
je le redis c'est une trace de mémoire
pour tous la jeunesse et les enfants de
la martinique
aujourd'hui on vous sent quand même du
jour ému la vérité c'est que ces dix
points wii est une empreinte
je le sais tout ce que je fais ou fin
toutes les luttes que je mène moi même
j'ai écrit un livre après la mort de mon
père qui s'appelle dire non un autre
livre récemment dire nous contre le
racisme l'islamophobie et tout ce qui
monte en france viennent de cette
empreinte cette empreinte je le redis
nous ne sommes jamais des individus
isolés - ce que j'ai appris dans ma vie
d'homme conscient c'est ici que je les a
pris nous allons passer à autre chose au
passé par les politiques
oui du coup l'émotion va me quitter sa
valeur
le président à hollande a décidé de ne
pas être candidat à la prochaine
présidentielle
canal a dit ce furent en fait vous l'a
écouté comme vous savez j'ai dit à
l'équipe de mediapart et aux lecteurs de
mediapart en septembre dernier qui était
ce sont des jeunes ils étaient tous
désespérés le climat en france est
actuellement très est désespérant et je
leur ai dit rien ne se passera comme
prévu hashtag rien ne se passera comme
prévu vous allez voir et vous avez vu
aux écologistes madame duflot était à
droite monsieur sarkozy est bon 3e et
monsieur fillon a fait la surprise
et voilà que hollande fait demi-tour que
cette histoire qui devait être écrite ne
se passe pas du tout comme annoncé par
les états majors
dans le cas de françois hollande c'est
le constat de son échec de l'échec pas
seulement du contenu du quinquennat mais
de l'échec par rapport à sa famille
politique que ce quinquennat n'aura pas
arrêté de diviser et le symbole non
seulement tous ces anciens ministres qui
sont candidats et qui était prêt à être
candidat contre lui c'est que le dernier
à lui avoir serré le cou pour lui dire
tu ne peux pas y aller pour laisser son
premier mini ce qu'il a fait c'est lui
qui a poussé valls et la nomination de
valve ça a été un moment de rupture
rappelez-vous valls a symbolisé une
soi-disant de gauche autoritaire qui a
flirté avec le camp identitaire avec les
idéologies diffusé par la droite extrême
et l'extrême droite qui s'est dressé
contre la diversité de la jeunesse je
rappelle que la première décision de
valls il ne faut jamais l'oublier
après 2012 c'est lui qui refuse les
décisions la promesse numéro 30 sur le
contrôle au faciès sur le fait que tous
ces jeunes qui en france dans leur
diversité se retrouve contrôlé par la
police à cause de leur couleur de leur
apparence vous voyez eh bien c'était
monsieur valls donc c'est le symbole de
ce quinquennat qui a divisé au lieu de
rassembler quels sont les enjeux
2 de ce quinquennat qui s'annonce là ce
qui s'annonce c'est cette campagne
présidentielle comme pour moi le
peut-être la dernière la dernière de ce
genre là rendez vous compte notre
système est épuisé les partis politiques
ne peuvent plus désigner leurs candidats
font appel à nous pour arbitrer leurs
divisions
ce ne sont pas des batailles de
programme entre dans les primaires ce
sont des batailles d'ego moi vous
connaissez ma position et en ce sens je
suis fidèle à ce contre quoi
alain plenel dont on parlait tout à
l'heure c'est dressé c'est le
présidentialisme qui épuise notre
démocratie nous sommes au 21ème siècle
on ne peut pas faire que la volonté de
tous se résume au choix d'un seul
nous avons besoin de délibérations nous
avons besoin d'horizontalité nous avons
besoin de pluralité nous avons besoin de
cette diversité par laquelle on est
intelligent à plusieurs et pas dans le
choix d'un seul
est ce que la gauche le ps a perdu
définitivement ces élections non quand
je dis rien ne se passera comme prévu il
peut se passer plein de choses d'abord
quelle gauche est ce monsieur macron
pour certains n'est pas de gauche mais
il était ministre et il va faire
campagne de son côté monsieur valse va
se battre avec monsieur montebourg on va
voir ce qui va sortir de ça et de
l'autre côté il ya monsieur mélenchon
qui dit venue du ps il l'a quitté il ya
huit ans la gauche c'est moi on va voir
ce qui va se passer on va voir quelle
dynamique la vérité la question c'est
qu'il ya aujourd'hui une dynamique de
droite dans la société on l'a vu au tour
de monsieur fillon autour du mariage
pour tous mais aussi social du fn
oui bien sûr de l'extrême droite qui
impose son agenda de son agenda
idéologique qui est identitaire
inégalitaire autoritaire donc la
question c'est comment et pour moi c'est
le défi de la société et pas des
candidats comment avoir dans la société
un autre agenda d'égalité de fraternité
de liberté et du plenel merci ça au cas
déterminé bonne journée à tous sociaux